[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Подніпров'я і Запоріжжя
Петриківка]
Привіт!
Зараз ми знаходимося в найбільшому центрі прикладного мистецтва України:
село Петриківка.
На жаль, справжньої петриківки дуже мало збереглося.
Дуже багато майстрів було,
дуже багато ремесел.
Люди що бачили — те і малювали.
От як ти хочеш, так і малюєш.
І коли говорять: «Петриківка малюється тільки червоним, зеленим чи оранжевим», —
немає такого!
Я навіть не уявляла,
я нічого не знала про старих майстрів.
[Наталя Рибак
Майстриня петриківського розпису]
Була фабрика «Дружба», це в 70-ті роки, там малювали одне й те саме тисячними тиражами.
Воно було все заключено в певні рамки,
тобто це гарантія, що робота пройде,
що художня рада прийме.
Деякі вважають, хто необізнаний,
що чорне тло притаманне петриківці.
Ні. Це Росія.
[Галина Назаренко
Майстриня петриківського розпису]
Але мені здається,
що завдяки тому чорному тлу
в той радянський період
петриківка збереглася.
Просто на кожному етапі
знаходився хтось, хто її зберігав.
Цілих 11 років, ще по війні, тут не було тут не було жодного підприємства,
[Андрій Пікуш
Сайстер петриківського розпису]
і розпис продовжував жити,
але виключно в підпільній формі.
Майстри намагалися ховатися
зі своїм мистецтвом,
я їх повідшукував,
я став запрошувати до них із Києва мистецтвознавців.
І вони відчули, що вони знову
стали потрібні людям.
Це моє робоче місце, я тут працюю.
Це моє життя!
І причому це невід'ємна його складова.
Якщо я довго не малюю — я просто хворію,
і це просто неможливо.
Оця частина розпису називається бігунець безкінечний «лиштва»:
є певний ритм, який весь час повторюється.
Така ось робота, ось дивіться, — сучасна робота.
Вона намальована пальчиком,
до фарби додається
яєчний жовток або клей ПВА,
за кожним разом занурюється і проводиться.
Але якщо ви неправильно
зробите хоч один рух,
ви зіпсуєте цілу роботу,
і виправити уже неможливо,
тому що це папір.
Тільки на ньому можна
використати всі ті прийоми,
які передавали нам предки
із покоління в покоління.
Хоча можна малювати і на стіні,
і на склі, і на металі,
і на пластмасі, і на дереві.
Але папір — це найулюбленіший мій,
і найцінніший матеріал.
А от дивіться, дівчата ось які, бачите?
Нічого спільного з Барбі,
іде — земля гуде.
Мурочка!
Мурочка! Дівчинка гарна!
Ой ти така гарна.
Давай ще трохи, на один,
більше не прошу.
От так перемовини і ведемо з кицькою.
Шерсть повинна лягати в одному напрямку:
гостреньке до гостренького, зріз до зріза.
«Котячка» — це у нас взагалі якийсь унікальний пензлик,
тому що нею можна і широкий мазок зробити,
і круглий, і найтонший.
Замінників ми не знайшли.
Оце скільки існує петриківський розпис...
І з вовка, і з зайця пробували,
і з лисиці,
то жодна шерсть не підійшла.
Кіт повинен бути непородистий,
дворовий, короткошерстний.
Ну чи кішка.
Навіть, до речі, з кішки кращі пензлики, ніж із кота.
Змотуємо.
Ось вона має такий вигляд. Бачите?
Вона така вже опрацьована,
кажуть: «Ой, слухайте,
подаруйте мені вашу стару щітку».
Та стара щітка — це найцінніше!
Нову можна подарувати,
а стару вироблену — ніколи!
Це знаєте, як налаштований інструмент,
коли продовження твоєї руки.
Ось ми беремо, наприклад,
таку червону фарбочку,
і починаємо працювати.
Це ми малюємо так названу цибульку,
бо нагадує розрізану навпіл цибулину.
Бачите, такі тонесенькі-тонесенькі лінії?
Це ми працювали кінчиком.
А тепер оцією п'яточкою.
І зараз ми малюємо листочки.
Ось дивіться як цікаво:
от ми беремо світлу фарбочку,
кінчик занурюємо в темно-зелену,
і виходить такий от перехід.
У кожного майстра — свій почерк,
його без підпису легко
розрізнити і пізнати.
Саме наш колектив Центру народного мистецтва
підготував виставку,
біля двохсот творів,
яка експонувалася в 50-ти країнах світу,
і забезпечила те досьє,
яке ввело петриківський розпис
у реєстр ЮНЕСКО.
Це вже тут пішли мої речі:
це гутне скло,
що виготовлено за моїми ескізами.
Тут є і дерево, і скло,
і кераміка, і розпис на папері.
Це моя перша закордонна виставка,
що була в Парижі.
А минулого року було
чотири виставки, де я їздила,
а п'ята вже без мене відбувалася
в Нью-Йорку в Українському інституті.
Потрібно вже дбати
про гарний імідж України за кордоном.
І петриківка — це те, що можна показати
з гарної позитивної сторони.
Ну те я і роблю.
А от чому? Ну, напевно, це моє життя.
Ну, не знаю. Малюю все життя.
Я сиджу, малюю. Це моє життя.
Якщо можна так назвати моє життя,
то, напевно, це життя у стилі джазу —
суцільна імпровізація,
і цьому я страшенно рада.
Тому я завжди з невеличким рюкзачком,
там у мене все є.
Так тільки махнули і я зразу поїхала,
без проблем абсолютно.
Мене це тільки радує.
Ну, власне, це моє життя.
Я вже понад 40 років, 45 років з ґаком
працюю у цій галузі.
І всіма силами, що можу,
намагаюся якось сприяти
його збереженню і розвитку,
бо це не просто лише краса, естетика.
Це ще й письмена!
І ще й символіка глибока!
Вічність життя утверджена в цих символах.
Людям не вистачає цієї гармонії.
І наш народ любить цю красу,
і прагне до неї, і хоче бачити,
і самі хочуть малювати.
Чим більше людей малюватиме...
Люди, які займаються народним мистецтвом,
нікому не можуть зробити шкоди.
Так що, я думаю, у мене
дуже багато ще роботи:
треба залучати до малювання всю Україну.
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператор
Павло Пашко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Сценаристка
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]